ironically what my producers told me
that Michael block was unavailable for
interview on Monday I had two short
phrases for them why not don't quit so
I'm delighted to say Michael block now
joins me live from the Colonial Country
Club in Texas Michael uh a great honor
to have you on Piers Morgan on Saturday
I want to start by the mission until
last week I'd never heard of you
um like probably most people who watched
you and then by the end of the week the
whole of American EU the whole world
knew you and you had endeared yourself
to tens of millions of people around the
world
how do you feel what's it been like to
be Michael Block in the last few days
it's probably Pierce uh I mean you know
how it feels but
for us average folks like me uh yeah
it's exactly what you would think your
brain just is numb uh it's insane you
can't comprehend what's even going on uh
it's nuts I'm literally just floating
around at this point and thank God I've
got a whole bunch of people here helping
me get through it and uh
I got a couple more interviews and then
uh I'm gonna I'm gonna get my my clubs
back out and practice all the afternoon
get ready for tomorrow's uh tournament
that was uh this is one of the great
benefits already you're being invited to
take part in in tournaments which you
wouldn't otherwise have been playing in
otherwise you'd have been back at your
local club uh teaching people how to
play this game that you you love you're
46 years old and you've had this Burning
dream for so long to actually realize
that dream to compete against the very
best in one of the great major
tournaments and then to drain that
ludicrous hole in one where you didn't
even need the ball to bounce like the
rest of us or go along the ground like
the rest of us it just went straight in
the hole with Rory McIlroy hagging you
thousands of Spectators going nuts
Millions watching at home going nuts
that moment I mean is that the dream
realized for you whatever happens next
you know I mean I've been playing
tournament golf for my goodness 40 years
I've never had a hole in one in a
tournament in my life and for the ball
to go directly into the hole is it was
almost like somebody just grabbed it out
of the air and threw it into the hole uh
under those circumstances it's
unbelievable and I guess that's why the
stories is what it is I mean I couldn't
have asked for a better timing of making
a shot in my entire life and it happened
under those circumstances playing with
one of my Idols Rory McIlroy playing
front of the Rochester New York fans who
were absolutely behind me a hundred
percent uh and I wasn't even thinking
about the millions of people behind all
the cameras I was just sitting there
wanting to let that crowd go absolutely
crazy and I guess I did exactly what I
needed to do on that hole you sowed so
much emotion throughout the whole
process of this tournament and yet your
wife has said that you never cried when
your kids were born when your two sons
or you're a very loving dad and they're
both very good young golfers you never
cried when they were born but you've
been weeping away for the last four days
how do you explain you find this more
emotional
oh boy
um
you could say I love the game of golf uh
unbelievably but
um I mean obviously I love my kids more
I love a lot of things more than golf
but golf is just this passion and it's a
sport and the only time I had ever cried
ever before I started crying about my
own game was watching Rudy and watching
the movie Rudy and when he puts that you
know the all the all the teammates come
in and put their jerseys down so Rudy
can play yeah that's the only other time
I remember ever having that emotional
state and actually coming to tears and
so now it's I feel like that every time
I hear somebody tell me these uh items
like I know I idea that I was in the
next PGA Championship or how much I won
or what other tournaments I got into and
every single time I hear these great
things uh it just brings me to tears and
uh it's it's been amazing and I am
definitely an emotional roller coaster I
know I mean one of the most
extraordinary of all the remarkable
moments you've had is that you've got to
think three or four thousand text
messages and you were told by somebody
from Nike look you better check them
because in the middle of them is one
from Michael Jordan who'd seen you were
wearing a pair of his sneakers
um have you found that text and what did
he say to you
the second that I got the word I go you
what I go Michael texted me I'm like I
didn't see it and they're like you're
kidding me I'm like no and so I just
started scrolling and scrolling and I've
literally thousands upon thousands of
texts and half of them don't have a name
and I definitely didn't have his name in
my contacts so I kept on scrolling
finally found it and he basically said
something down to the lines that uh this
is why he loves the game of golf so much
and uh my big request from him is that I
want to spend one of those days with him
at his course and play 36 holes with him
and his friends and that just that just
will make my life complete I mean
Michael Jordan it's for many the
greatest athlete to ever play any sport
to be taking time out of his his life to
text you Michael block uh that's a
remarkable thing right
uh
uh I don't think uh you know outside of
my friends and family nobody ever texted
me before last week so yeah having
Michael Jordan and all the other texts
I've had since then it's ridiculously
fun and exciting and very very surreal
what does your wife say about this I
mean she's being say behind every great
man is a greater woman she's lived this
dream with you I guess vicariously
through the good and bad often bad I
guess uh often tough certainly it's not
easy to be a journeyman professional
golfer how important is she being to you
unbelievable she's been uh she's been
there for me all the way uh she stood by
me you know when I was making eight
dollars and fifty cents when I started
my job uh and I always said trust me
honey trust me I'm always going to have
you covered uh ever since then and I've
that's been always my goal right to be
able to raise my family in a in a great
spot in southern Orange County in in
California which is isn't easy and uh
it's been huge and she's just a rock for
me
um and she understands what I've been
through the good and the bad and uh she
is she's going to come in hopefully
Saturday here to uh Fort Worth I just
have to make the cut what did your boys
say because I know at least one of them
often caddies for you but didn't on this
occasion what did they make of this
their dad their hero suddenly becoming
the world's hero
I've never you know
I've never heard my oldest one say so
many positive things about me usually
you know I was always the enemy and the
and the uh you know the guy that he was
trying to beat on the golf course and
you know my youngest one Ethan he's he's
a sweetheart he's always been the same
way but now all of a sudden Dylan's
chimed in and and he thinks dad's pretty
cool now so uh it's pretty awesome you
know it's pretty awesome as a father
that has a 16 and 18 year old boys uh
for them to look up to their pops is uh
is really awesome and I haven't seen him
since I had not I've not seen him for
one second so I can't wait to be back in
California here in the Whatever It Is by
hopefully Sunday night and uh give them
big hugs Dylan of course was cutting for
you when you had a low moment I think in
2018 you're feeling low about your game
and he said look in your shoes Dad and
it just said the words don't quit how
important was that moment to you
he was 13 years old I just made a triple
bogey I had to finish in the top 20 of
that tournament to get into the PGA
Championship in 2018 at Bellerive
Country Club in St Louis I grew up a
mile from Bellerive Country Club so it
was my number one priority checklist to
make happen so I'm walking off this hole
just making a horrible mess of it triple
bogey and I'm walking off he's 13. he's
like this this High raise a little guy
and and he says Hey Dad he goes dad did
you look in your shoes and um I'm like
no buddy I just got these last week and
uh he goes he goes it says don't quit so
you're not going to quit on me and I I
mean I I got emotional at that point too
and I'm like my kids saying it to me I
mean come on let's go and I I've
refocused and I got into a playoff I
made a birdie in the playoff and I got
into the PGA Championship in 2018 which
is which was Unreal it's amazing and it
was also amazing that your golf balls
have the words why not and the story is
great where you're qualifying for the US
opening a 22 foot pot why not is what
you and your caddy you said why not why
shouldn't I get this in and you had the
same attitude actually I watched the
interviews as you progressed in the PGA
tournament you just kept thinking rather
than downplaying the fact you were there
why shouldn't I be here I'm a
professional golfer on my day I can
compete with these guys but to actually
then compete with these guys at their
level to be with Rory McIlroy and play
as well as he did on that final day that
that for you as a golfer what a moment
I'll tell you what uh everyone should
live that way you know whether it's
going to a business meeting or a sport
or going to your softball game or
whatever it might be I mean if you live
without Mantra why can't it happen to me
uh it's gonna work it's a positive you
know one of the biggest things for me is
to take the negatives out of the uh out
of the brain and replace them with
positive so if I'm thinking positively I
can't think about two things at the same
time so I'm going to keep focusing on
that and that's worked out beautifully
for me
um so I keep that Mantra going and I
kept it going last week I'm Gonna Keep
it going this week and hopefully the
rest of my life and I'm trying to teach
my boys to do the same thing and for
people
watching this who have their own dream
whatever it is not necessarily golf just
a dream in life
you've you've realized your dream at 46
where many may have given up hope what
is your message to people living a dream
of any age
give them what you've just achieved
well if you're passionate about it and
you work as hard as you possibly can
you're going to give yourself the best
opportunity to have it happen is it a
guaranteed to have happen absolutely not
but at the end of the day
you know when when you're you're about
to leave this this planet
um you can look back at it and you said
I gave it 100 because the last thing I'm
going to do is leave this planet
thinking I only gave it 60 or hey you
know maybe I'm maybe I'm just too tired
I'm gonna go home and relax now go out
play that extra nine go out practice a
little harder go work on that you know
presentation you're going to give the
next day a little harder give it that
extra 100 and uh when it's all said and
done you'll be way happier about it for
yourself
finally Michael uh it's traditional of
course whoever gets a hole in one in
golf buys everybody in the clubhouse a
drink and in fact Brooks kepco won the
tournament when he saw you when I hear
the beers are on you buddy or worse of
that effect when you go back to your
Club will you be buying everybody in
that Clubhouse or we're going nuts on
your behalf watching their Pro take the
PGA by storm you're going to go back and
buy them all a drink
a hundred percent thanks Pierce for
saying that you know they're going to
take me for sure up on that now so yeah
I will I will as long as they were in
there for that you know when they were
going nuts when that hole in one
everybody that was in there at that
point without a doubt drinks are on me
when I get back
and just to clarify the moment you knew
you'd got that hole in one
Better Than Sex Michael
[Laughter]
absolutely not
you thought about that I don't even saw
that's a genuine answer but you thought
your wife's watching this didn't you be
honest yeah
you're horrible that was great though
Michael yeah I'm gonna get some for that
you are you eventually you managed to
get the right right answer out what did
Rory McIlroy say to you just finally
because you were playing with this great
guy he was so moved I think by the whole
experience he said you have bigger
crowds following you than him and he
hugged you at the end what did he say to
you
oh he was he was uh instrumental uh how
sweet he was and how nice he was to me
the entire time took me under his wing
as did Rosie on Saturday uh that was
huge
um that's probably one of the reasons I
was able to shoot a 71 that final round
and and have that stuff happen but uh he
just said keep it going just be you
that's what I kept in here from a lot of
the guys just be you keep keep doing
what you're doing and that's what I'm
gonna do I'm just trying to be me still
I'm out here in in Texas now I'm gonna
do the exact same thing I did last week
does that guarantee that I'm gonna have
a hole in one or finish 15th absolutely
not but you guys all know that at the
end of the day that when I leave here
and when I leave Texas go back to
California I gave it everything I had
Michael you're fantastic honestly I
loved the interviews through the
progress of that tournament I loved the
hole in one I love the magic of it all I
love the hope and inspiration you've
given every golfer like me in the world
playing around of 16 and hoping that one
day maybe we could do what you did you
lived a dream for a lot of us a lot of
Pros a lot of everyone actually living a
dream out there thank you for that and
congratulations honestly it's one of the
great Sports stories of recent years and
I I loved every second of it
hey Pierce thank you so much and uh
thanks for having me on
good to see you